hi i'm evan carmichael and in this video
i wanted to answer a question from one
of my readers
freestyles who owns a website called
local arena
and is having a hard time figuring out
how much his business is worth
because he wants to raise equity capital
from getting an investor on board
so a little bit of background on the
business they have put around 15 000
worth of services into the business and
they're generating revenue of about 1200
per month so he's figuring out how much
is my business worth and so he's gotten
different valuations from investors and
one in my opinion
so i've been in the vc world before and
we were raising half a million fifteen
million dollars for companies
and valuation is something that we
always looked at and the cost-based
valuation
rarely works so to say well i put
fifteen thousand dollars into my
business so it's worth
x amount is really hard to justify
unless it's an asset that they can go
and sell so if you bought a piece of
land you bought some equipment that they
can sell easily has that
tangible asset value then that's where
you can look at
cost space usually you're going to look
at how much the company is going to be
worth and you want to look at the
revenue generated
now if you see the business that is not
it's not doesn't have a lot of growth
opportunity
web-based businesses will typically sell
for one to three times annual revenue
so if you see it growing slowly then you
might be
looking in that range so figure out how
much you're going to make for the year
time's up by one to three and that's
roughly what your company is going to be
worth
but if you see it as a high growth
opportunity so that 1200 you're making a
month you see that you know
being 100 times that then
you want to basically look at those
growth projections and that's typically
what a vc or venture capitalist or angel
will look at
they'll look at for the next five years
they'll want to see what your
projections are
so you know this year how much you're
gonna make next year the next year the
next year the next year so five years
out
how much you're going to be making and
what we do is usually discount that
value back so
look at how much you're going to be
earning you know for those five years
discount that back to today and you get
a rough valuation of how much you'll be
making
you have to justify that somehow and a
lot of times it's just
it's projection right so it's a guess
but you want to have confidence in those
numbers and the more confident you
are and the better you can explain your
rationale for getting to those numbers
the more faith you have from an investor
and the more likely you'll get a better
valuation
at the end of the day it's still up to
you and the investor to
come up with that valuation the further
along you are in your goals the
better valuation you get the closer you
are to startup
usually the worst value you get so it's
great that you already have some
customers you already have some revenue
coming in
a couple things to think about if you
want to get a better valuation if you
know you need to raise 50
000 what you might say is i need 10 000
at this valuation and if
i hit these certain milestones so maybe
maybe a target doesn't get five thousand
dollars a month
you say if i get the five thousand
dollars a month then i need another
twenty five thousand dollars but i have
a better valuation
then if we hit fifteen thousand dollars
a month then i need another twenty five
thousand dollars
at a better valuation or whatever it is
so you if you need 50 000
maybe you don't need it all up front and
you can phase it out over a period of
time
you feed milestones you agree with the
investor every time you raise the
capital
it's at a cheaper rate so you're not
giving up as much equity and you're
still getting the money
you need but it requires you to actually
go and hit the targets that you set out
so you better make sure you can actually
hit those targets
the last thing i would encourage you to
think about when bringing on investor
is don't just go for somebody with money
especially in this early stage if you're
looking for an angel investor
you want somebody who can help you so
somebody who has contacts who can
introduce you to people who can get you
out there and help promote your product
beyond just somebody who
gives you money and either you know
completely stays away from the business
or worse tries to interfere and doesn't
really know much about your business and
and starts to uh drag it down a little
bit so think about who the person coming
in
is it's a lot like getting married you
got to really like the person they have
to have
a lot of potential to help you so really
focus on who that person is before
making the decision
i hope that helped if you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up
and i'd also love to hear your thoughts
and feedback if you want to leave a
comment below the video
and stay tuned for the next episode
you